ah
[Música]
no hay mal que por bien no venga' que
dicen las crisis traen oportunidades
para ver el arco iris primero tener a
contarte la lluvia en
sant y pones a pensar y es como muy
motivante porque siempre tiene que pasar
por un sufrimiento para llegar a un
objetivo o algo no
bueno les vengo a contar un poco eso que
es un poco la constante de muchos años
de mi vida
piedras en el camino para llegar al
objetivo
pero por lo que no detectan que soy la
cabra que abrí cumplían a que voy
corriendo las piedras y voy por el
objetivo
de chico
me gustaba dibujar dibujar hacía
revistas a mano
dibujados los avisos muchos de esos
avisos que dibujaba hoy tengo la suerte
de trabajar para esas marcas y era la
única materia que tenía 10
y ganaba algunos concursos provinciales
parecía que venía por aquí las dos
yo siempre decía que va a estudiar
dibujo publicitario de donde lo saque
por con digamos con mi familia de
rosario la entrada de rosario lugar
enorme que decía dibujo publicitario
quinto año cuando quisiera preguntar
pero quiero nueva estación imprenta acá
no nos enseña nada entonces volví quinto
año con mi profesora del barça pero nos
pusimos a verla la guía de estudios de
carreras y apareció esta carrera nueva
llamada diseño gráfico hacía un año
estaba en buenos aires
pusimos a leer y dijimos con él más o
menos lo que yo te gustó ya fuimos con
el apoyo incondicional de mi familia
obviamente mi abuela nieta mi mamá
estela bueno mi familia con mi mamá
estela nos fuimos a buenos aires a notar
mención universitaria llegó
un bloque de cemento 40 mil personas
adentro acampar campañas políticas
tremendo nos anotamos cuando salimos
estela me dice digo no cree se estudia
la arquitectura del rosario
de hoy y es que ya está llamando t pero
vieron la voz de la madre siempre se
quedaron y aunque se ha pensado no había
morir de hambre es una carrera nueva no
conoce nadie dice ni bravas ya que se
tome a morir de hambre entonces por las
dudas empieza a estudiar arquitectura al
mismo tiempo
seis meses de la mitad de mitad del año
viene un profesor y me dice viven parece
que lo tuyo va por el diseño y odios más
ahora ha visto unas dotes creativas muy
buenos dios dice no pos visto algún
arquitecto que le ponga color a los
planos
bueno probablemente no es lo mío vieron
algún arquitecto que color en los planos
no hay entonces seguí con mi rumbo al
mismo tiempo oro los dos solos nos
pusimos a buscar un lugar donde vivir
pensión en roces en buenos aires
timbre por timbre llegamos hasta el
microcentro enfrente hablando con los
porteros los edificios enfrente el luna
park encontramos una pensión una muy
linda pensión la mentira
era la atención del viejo rey gallego
rey que era todo un pasillo pero
habitaciones dobles por suerte no
compartía con nadie con un baño
compartido atrás
un bajón pero bueno yo estudiaba la
mañana ha trabajado a la tarde ya la
noche tenía que dibujar
y el viejo rey no quería que gaste luz
es entonces cuando veía que venir clic
porque allí todos en la noche cortaba la
luz y cuando veía que he escuchado los
pasos del viejo rey
yo ahora voy a apagar la luz y seguía
dibujando con la linterna tenía que
terminar
recuerdo cuando me mandaron prestado un
tablero placa de casilda para allá
cuando llega el viejo rey dice pero
usted quiere es miguel ángel no entendía
nada que tiene un tablero grande para
dibujar
bueno para ahí empezaron mis viajes
continuos a buenos aires
con viajante abrigo a quien viajaba el
famoso transporte y vale el transporte
sponsor del evento que después tuve la
alegría de diseñar su marca y ahí empezó
para bancar me tuve que empezar a buscar
trabajos estoy yo siempre digo que trato
trataba siempre de sacarle el lado
positivo a todos mis trabajos no te
queda otra digo me dieron una docente
puede ser que yo le sacaba todo
el primer trabajo repartir cartillas
médicas en la calle nos daban técnicas
para entrar a edificios técnicas porque
la delincuencia en boga pues que tengo
que colarnos el edificio tocar timbre
hard una cartilla médica y pasar al otro
día para ver si le había gustado
que tiene de positivo eso que era
empezar a conocer los barrios de buenos
aires- moverme
y las penas técnicas de ventas empezará
a rociar a rodearme un poquito con la
avenida al tiempo un amigo me consiguió
en una gráfica de stands que tenemos que
calcar los logos de la marca dibujarla
atrás del contact y cortarlas e ir a
pegar las que tiene bueno
obvio mi acercamiento con los logos y
las tipografías y empezar a dibujar
letras pero como en el verano se cortaba
no había exposición no había ferias
entonces vine acá a sila y realizó una
una exposición en un banco de acá
entonces mi viejo pp me ayudó con todos
los soportes de madera para poner todo
mi trabajo de la facultad hice una
muerte la filme cuando volvimos a clases
se la llevó a al director de la carrera
gonzález ruiz que era el fundador de la
carrera el director de cátedra que yo
estudié a la semana me llama para
trabajar en su estudio para mí era como
tocar el cielo con las manos y un
posgrado pago tuve un año y medio
mi acercamiento con señalización de
buenos aires- imágenes de bancos fueron
pizzi y eran
los cartones
pintado lo que se hacía
al tiempo por eso digo que siempre traté
siempre de matarme en cada en cada lugar
dónde estaba entonces en la facultad yo
realmente me mataba entonces un
compañero a veces no sabes dónde bien
las oportunidades un compañero sabía que
yo era buen alumno me me recomendó para
esta empresa la empresa
más conocida de golosinas del país que
estaba armando su departamento de pacas
porque los noventas la explosión del
marketing cuando entré había tres
personas de marketing y cuando me fui
150 entonces viví durante 6 años toda la
explosión que me permitió conocer a mis
clientes que eran mis compañeros de
trabajo y para darle miedo al cliente y
obviamente con 23 años poder diseñar
golosinas que veían todos los que las
lentejas de chocolate digo de los
chicles mi último proyecto en arcore fue
rediseñar estas famosas pastillas que
eran las que más vendían en la empresa
millón de la dirección y enfiló mirada
de llamar al mejor estudio de buenos
aires para competir porque es un
proyecto muy importante no son testeo y
tuve la suerte de que salga seleccionada
mi idea entonces tomé contacto en este
estudio y a las 23 meses estaba en una
búsqueda de me presenté y y entré en
este estudio este estudio era pasar de
diseñar golosinas que era color
personajes a vinos cerveza primera no me
salía nada pero tenía que aprender una
nueva industria pues seis años me fue
muy bien voy a dirigir un equipo
[Música]
qué pasó 2001 crisis nos sientan a todos
nos dice como 30 dice echamos a la mitad
o nos bajamos todo el sueldo a la mitad
obviamente es bueno nos bajamos a la
mitad
y pasó un año y medio si seguimos
pagando la mitad así que bueno me tuve
que ir no podía pagar el crédito no
tenía un bebé chico
así que me fui a la otra consultora de
branding por dos años aprender el otro
lado de la vereda tuve la suerte en esas
en esos años de estar en esos lugares
que fue el desembarco del branding en la
región
los hobbies que son los hobbies yo tengo
un conflicto con los hobbies por cada
hobby que ha dado después lo terminó
funcionando con mi trabajo y deja de ser
joven no ya no sé qué hobby que trabajo
pero viajo y saco fotos vamos por amigos
a ver tendencias a otro país y yo saco
fotos escribe una nota aprovechó todo
mis hobbies los aprovecho a todos
hago fotos lo que le llamo street creen
que son
y volví eso después durante dos años fue
la tapa de una revista semanal de
marketing y dice y publicidad
entonces
los hobbies yo les conté antes qué
yo me gusta dibujar letras entonces
durante cuatro años estuve pensando una
letra para computadoras que sea
caligráfica y que no se note el renglón
que no se note que no sea mecánica mis
amigos me decían para que una letra más
en la pc hay 200 para que bueno hasta
que la vio
un dueño de una revista prestigiosa de
buenos aires y me hizo una nota
después tomé contacto con él a los 23
meses me llama que dice vos estuviste
trabajando en londres querés hacer una
nota de packaging inglés listo seis
páginas de pacas en inglés pues yo me
haya traído un montón de cosas productos
dije está buenísimo a los meses me llamo
vice digo a fin de año vamos a hacer un
evento internacional para 800 personas
en el hotel más igual de buenos aires
prepárate bien en cinco oradores
extranjeros muy grosos y elijo a cinco
de argentina y vos sos uno imagínense yo
no le podía hablar a diez pibes en la
facultad no voy a dar clase a 10 pibe
bueno no me salía con la timidez agarre
empecé a estudiar teatro oratoria
agarraba todas las charlas que me
invitaban llevaba a la chica de prensa
me decía diego podéis abrir la boca para
hablar cosas así muy motivantes hasta
que pude dar esa famosa charla y con
tanta fortuna que haya delante de
nuestra ustedes esta había un jurado de
los premios konex los premios konex son
premios muy prestigiosos que se dan cada
10 años a una disciplina en este caso de
artes visuales y elegían cinco
diseñadores por la obra de los últimos
diez años y en ese año quería premiar a
jóvenes no a próceres
o sea de un hobby de una letra a un
premio konex entonces miren si lo de
importancia a los hobbies
ahora no es todo color de rosa cuando
conté la agencia donde trabajaba que
había sido nominado querían obligarme a
que devuelva el premio si
es alguna pronto te conoces alguien que
haya devuelto un premio konex o sea es
imposible o bien te dije que no y bueno
obviamente algo empezó a andar mal al
mismo tiempo empezamos a armar un
estudio un estudio una agencia con dos
compañeros de trabajo durante un tiempo
ya estábamos por salir y llegar al
momento
11 los dos necesitaron un bar de palermo
y me dicen diego vamos a hacer la
agencia pero nosotros vos no
quedamos así nos vemos
y bueno yo tengo un problema que yo no
tengo plan de yo voy al plan nada y
bueno yo soy bueno me hago pedazos y
vuelvo a hacer otro plan y bueno lo veo
la distancia es el mejor favor que me
hicieron en su vida
agarre dije junte fuerzas y me pongo por
mi cuenta empecé en el altillo de mi
casa con una computadora un celular un
cliente esta famosa empresa de golosinas
que quería sacar su línea de helados
y con eso y con un crédito pre acordado
por las dudas para que tenía a juancito
dos meses por las dudas para la obras
sociales y entonces empecé a trabajar
bien en un estado domingo manda un mail
el viernes 5 la tarde iba el sábado
chequeando estado la tarde el domingo y
vídeo que no me contestaba yo estaba
como loco y luego entendí que los
clientes no trabaja en el censo
pero estaba como loco y
le auguraban
24/7 después me pudo alquilar una
oficinita en puerto madero y muy
chiquitita y viene un consultor y me
dice diego a esta oficina no le pongas
ni un peso porque acá dos años en el
equipo no te queda chica o te tenés que
ir a tu casa fundido ágil conserje
pequeño todo muy muy muy muy motivante
por suerte al año y medio me tuve que ir
porque para un formato que si no crece
tenía chico y empecé empecé a trabajar
empezamos a crecer éramos 15 personas
representando en guatemala en ecuador
ocho años así de explosivos que yo
quería ser como estas consultoras de las
que había trabajado hasta en los
momentos agarró y me miró a mí mismo y
digo estoy estoy más con los contadores
que con las ideas sólo elegí esto al
mismo tiempo me encontré con la frase el
diseñador alan fletcher un inglés que ya
no está con nosotros un genio te decía
que el diseño no es lo que el cliente
esperaría ver sino lo que nunca imaginó
que quería
al mismo tiempo le hice una nota a un
gerente martes para hablar de diseño y
dice yo el gerente para donde los
alfajores marplatenses dice yo lo que
valoro de un diseñador es esa mirada en
abril y no a línea de que me haga salir
de caja pero hace 10 años esté tratando
de pensar como los clientes y ellos
quieren que los desafíos dije algo estoy
haciendo mal
o sea me hizo un clic empecé a
desarrollar un concepto que hoy me
acompañó hasta el día de hoy se llama el
concepto vale es volver a la esencia del
diseño pues me di cuenta que me gustaba
eso dibujar hacer letras caligrafía es
lo que me gustaba quería volver a es
todo empecé a rodear de chicos que
vengan sin experiencia ilustradores del
calígrafo metering venían y me sean
diego nunca hice un pack así no tengo
experiencia mejor venir porque crear mi
propio estilo pero por otro lado si
traigo gente que venga de otros estudios
y estudio va a trabajar como es va a
tener trabajos con si fueran esos
estudios no tengo un diferencial
y la verdad bueno empezamos mucho
trabajo para alomar consolidar este
equipo y hace ocho años ya la agencia
tiene 17 y hoy gracias a dios nos vienen
a buscar por esa mirada no alineada esa
mirada disruptiva esa frescura
así que siempre digo que antes puse la
pasión por sobre el negocio
y hasta
me fui dando con esto de las expresiones
artísticas estás y hacer hace un par de
años una muestra en nueva york una
muestra de arte con todos los trabajos
que hicimos para clientes
siempre digo que
siempre me preparé para diseñar una
bebida pero nunca nadie me enseñó a
diseñar una vida entonces siento a veces
que mi vida
es como
los electrocardiogramas que tik tik tik
y a veces siento decir a veces digo sí
estaría bueno ser un poquito más así
pero bueno
cosas muy muy arriba abajo no sé tener
una vocación que te encanta pero es en
buenos aires en dejar a tus amigos a tu
familia voy a una pensión el tipo me
corta la luz
voy a vivir con la señora que me
cocinaba y todo llegó la facultad le
encuentra muerta
no sé cuándo va a terminar
compramos nuestra primera casa
2001 tengo que vender por el crédito se
fue por las nubes 2000 nace nuestro
primer hijo
nace con una unidad de pragmática de 10
días y fallece
tenemos los dos hijos tengo los dos
bombones son la alegría de mi vida fue
'la y martín a
me cagan los socios ganó el premio konex
quieren que lo devuelva o sea
cuando para esto
bueno todo eso para tener una agencia
prestigiosa o vivir de lo que uno eligió
como vocación que era el primero
entonces a veces yo digo esto
porque es tan así porque es tan así
después entendí que si la línea recta es
porque estás
estás muerto y yo la verdad que soy un
apasionado de la vida de la calidad de
vida describe el disfrutar
y la verdad que hoy sigo siempre
eligiendo 100 y dijo vivir y la vida
[Aplausos]
[Música]